hi there Steve here again continuing to
report on my 90-day Korean challenge so
today I want to talk about patience
because I think patients is something
very important in language learning we
don't want to put pressure on ourselves
if we put pressure on ourselves we say
we're not learning fast enough I wish I
were better that's not very productive
it doesn't help and and I kind of
thought this today as I say like relax
Steve you're not moving you know you
still don't understand as well as you
would like but I am enjoying reading
these podcasts and then listening to
them not understanding very well but
reading them saving words learning about
events in Korea and doing all of this is
just continuing to get my brain more and
more used to Korean and I don't speak a
lot and but today for example I was in
the office and one thing I've started
doing is is I can print out I got can
save phrases as I'm going through these
different texts i saved phrases so i'll
take 20 phrases that I don't fully
understand I sit down with Hannah I said
Hannah we're going to speak Korean and I
want you to explain these phrases to me
we went through the 20 phrases in Korean
I was doing fine and and you know this
whole idea of being patient I was
thinking about it today i was in
CrossFit so in CrossFit you know you the
basically crossfit if you haven't been
in the CrossFit you begin by doing a
certain warm-up exercises today we had
you know three reps of push-ups followed
by barbell curl dumbbell curls while
we're in squatting position and then we
were sort of stretching on some these
elastic bands do that three times then
we had to we have the floor press I
don't know what they call that to a
maximum weight and then we had to work
out of the day the workout of the day
was skipping rope 100 the rope skips
followed by wall balls wall ball is you
have a like a 14-pound ball you go down
into a squat and you come up
and you have to push the thing above a
certain line and we had to do 50 of
those so no we have to do 100 we had to
do 100 and then we have to do that four
times and oh and then we have then we
had to do lunges carrying you know like
25 pounds over our heads and you sort of
lunge you know touch your knee to the
floor we had to do 10 of 20 of those and
then we have to do 30 sit ups and then
we go back to the skipping and we have
to do that four times so okay like the
first time you do it and you sort of
under a certain amount of pressure
especially that the the wall balls where
you're kind of coming up out of a
squadron throwing the ball out there and
after and I say jeez I'm not going to
make it you know four rounds and then
you say slow down and you know almost
enjoy each squad enjoy each time you
throw the ball one at a time it's not a
race some of the other people may finish
before you do just do the squats and
enjoy it and it helps in a way if the
more you put pressure on yourself the
more daunting the task seems so it's the
same with language you're not competing
with anyone you know that by exposing
yourself to the language whatever you're
doing listening reading speaking your
brain is getting more and more used to
the language and just accept it and have
patience and so that is my message for
the day remember to be patient and enjoy
the moment there you have it bye for now